[Music]
you know speaking of stars and babies
it's kevin hart ready for babies with
his new wife eniko we talked family sex
life nothing was off limits when I hit
the set of his new movie untouchable in
Philly it's tough up tight right now but
it's the character man I'm really giving
it in my hall and it required this it
looks like a brillo pad that hurt in
your love life is it hurt you the hair
ya know this is how I know she really
loved this this is the test right here
you know what an ego really is all woman
to love her man in any form Kevin's
growing out that hair and beard for the
film he's shooting right now untouchable
with Bryan Cranston and Nicole Kidman
made my wife had an amazing place you
know we're still newlyweds do you think
you guys will start there is it hot it's
about having the patience to deal with
another kid see my kids are old enough
where I can say go do something right
and they go do something I gotta make
sure I have the patience to follow a
baby like that that ager that baby is
just calling you all the time that's a
tough age dad dad dad dad dad dad then
you finally turn around they go look I
caught up with the estimated 87.5
million dollar man on set and check this
out his custom-built workout trailer it
goes everywhere Kevin goals so he can
get in those 5 30 and workouts it's also
the place where they took advantage of
me that's right a dresser at a time but
at the same time Oh same town Kevin okay
ready at the same time all right here we
go campaign or girlfriend ya can Oh your
way right hahaha for ya 67 k what do you
think of my workout was but what do you
mean what it was it ain't gonna be great
the first time okay and in your defense
you had on jeans and dress shoes yeah
that's what did it what's next for Kevin
well see if you can keep up he's got the
secret life of pets to a book tour in
june a comedy tour next year his move
with heart cross country workout
initiative plus his turn up tuesdays
we camp just goes on Instagram and
dances just to make y'all feel good okay
so care wouldn't you relaxing I don't
want to relax why man no I'm still young
if I was your age it would be different
don't move my legs
[Music]
you